to really love a guy like that gotcha by
the way Quick stats uh how much does the
average man in America make if you know
the answer don't say it because you
probably how much 33 000 33 000 okay 46
46.
Heather I'd say like 50 50. do you know
the answer hold on before you give it
uh Natalia I would say like I mean
hopefully like 50. average man 50 gotcha
45 but I feel like it went up in the
last year or two to 50 something you
ready for this the average man in
America makes 38 000 a year okay wow um
how much does the average woman in
America make average woman Emily okay I
don't think that's a fair statistic
because a lot of women are stay-at-home
mothers and technically they don't make
an income
well it's still a statistic whether it's
fair there are statistics I looked at
last night there's only a three percent
difference between women who are married
if they have jobs or not
three percent difference all right well
stay stay-at-home moms are people so you
just made fun of stay-at-home moms they
they got I'm saying they have they are
people too Heather they you're going to
be a station
when you when you marry that guy who
makes 10 figures or eight figures or
whatever
you're gonna probably be a stay-at-home
mom yeah well he's not gonna care about
your law degree at that point he's like
a lot of Grace from autograph [__]
run Amazon you're taking care of the
kids anyway so I'll say this again what
do you think the average woman makes in
America today what number
the man's number is 38 000 a year
average now obviously everyone here is
above average and everyone's doing great
but this is how math works you know well
I would say women probably make it on
average less so I would say 30. Okay 30.
Pearl what's your number I would guess
this 30.
I'm just gonna do something different
I'm gonna say 40. okay so you're saying
more than men yeah oh wow that's female
empowerment right there ladies and
gentlemen
she took my 40. I was gonna I'll just go
with 38. just go 41 then okay not I'd
say 28. 28. Deli throw a number your way
just making sure you're awake
32 32 the average woman American makes
25 000. that's 13 lessons okay here we
go what percentage of men makes six
figures or more in America today six
figures or more you can include
stay-at-home moms in this weird figure
right now
let's start this way what percentage of
men make over six figures better people
are we including stay-at-home moms no
we're just talking men okay what
percentage of men make a hundred
thousand dollars or more I'm gonna say
30. 30 percent okay Jamie
like ten percent ten percent pearly
things
I feel like it's ten percent but I'm
gonna say eight to switch it up oh
Heather I'm gonna say seven seven uh
[Music]
five
okay I'll give you a hint what number
was Dan Marino
who's Dan Marino I don't know amazing
amazing
Dan Marino was number 13. 13 of men make
a hundred thousand dollars or more okay
so that means nine out of ten guys
almost are not making six figures okay
higher than I thought it was yeah I
actually thought it was 15. so okay it's
now 13. by the way fun fact what
percentage of women
make a hundred thousand dollars or more
are you raising your hands you can speak
as much as you want no I'm saying I
think he's going with five yeah he's
taking the over under I'll keep seven
seven
oh man I don't know probably a smaller
amount
um I'm gonna go with eleven eleven
twelve point seven six that's a pizza
rating Matt
um I'll stick with five five all right
so the answer is six you're very close
so just to be clear the average man in
America made thirty eight thousand
dollars a year the average woman makes
twenty five thousand okay thirteen
percent of men make over a hundred
thousand dollars a year six percent of
women make a hundred thousand dollars a
year when you hear these numbers what's
the first thing that comes to mind
anything stick out to you I'm a badass
so you're a badass
six percent okay
well
well I'm just thinking it's like okay
three of them here want guys that make
six figures
how many are actually gonna get it and
that's why they say like 45 percent of
women will be single and childless
amazing stat Morgan Stanley I do think
that all of us here are in that small
percentage of women so that puts us at a
higher status to get that higher status
man as well okay yeah I think as I made
more money I started surrounding myself
with men who made more money so now the
rooms that I'm in like I'm not really in
rooms where men are making 30 grand like
those aren't even the men that I'm
having conversations with don't this is
such a perfect setup for you I asked you
the question like what like what type of
Lifestyle like how can what should women
do with their life or like what's the
ideal situation you said well men lead
women follow right and I said well what
does that mean like what are you telling
an 18 year old girl to do and you said
prioritize finding a man right remember
this conversation and put yourself in
situations where you can find that man
and recognize what you want so you gave
the example of like the girl who would
like did the concessions yeah yeah like
the VIP at like whatever basketball game
and you were like well tell that story
oh I was so I had box seats the other
day my Dad's friend like gave it to our
family so we went and um I didn't
realize how expensive box seats are like
they're like it's like you have to pay
like 100k for the year or something I'm
like that's crazy and
um so basically when we were there
everyone that's up there is worth like
millions of dollars and there was a girl
going by and doing the desserts at every
place and I was just thinking she was
fumbling a bag because this girl was
obese and I was like girl if you were
like skinny and in shape and like pretty
like you could you could bag one of
these guys and so I was thinking that if
you were going to go that route like you
really wanted a rich guy to like get one
of those jobs
such a powerful such a problem
if you're that rich dude or if you're a
bunch of dudes and you're in the VIP
what is this like the club this is
wherever it is and a bad he walks in and
she's the convenience cart girl hey guys
time for dessert if you're a successful
guy you're like I'm gonna take you away
who's this girl like just quit your job
right now you just now got box seats
you're hanging with us but if you're a
fat girl it's like yeah I'll take the
[__] eclair all right keep it moving
there chunky like that's just the
reality I think there are about women
who are confident in men like that all
right Adam do you wanna do you want to
hook up with a girl that's confident or
hot well obviously hot and I will say
this
I know plenty of guys that will
bag of fatty for one night like a chubby
chaser like they'll take her down and be
like yeah bro like I I banged a big a
BBW girl like yeah okay like they'll
they'll kind of discreetly talk about it
but they ain't taking her out in public
homie they'll take her to a restaurant
dark like don't nobody know me they'll
do whatever they're not they're not like
you're talking about like a bridge troll
though like there's a difference between
a bridge toll and a bigger woman who
like but why do we handle this it's not
like we tell short broke men be
confident we do absolutely nothing
they call him I don't want no scrub a
scrub like that's a song we don't tell
them to be confident
for some reason fat chicks get special
treatment I don't get it I think it's
also interesting that I don't know maybe
100 150 years ago fat people in general
were considered the beauty standard so
bodies in our entire universe have been
very cyclical trends
when there were big girls were like all
the rage so let's say a hundred years
ago where they're all over the world in
the U.S there were Faith classes or like
surf Dums and there were people who had
money
you mean a thousand years ago or 200 I
don't know I'm not a mathematician like
you Adam
they're definitely like you can give me
a tangible example of whatever the
bigger girls were getting all the love
the other example I always get is some
tribe in Africa
I don't think it's real but I've heard a
lot about it on the show that's always
the excess
[Laughter]
I'm sure it's all happening it's a
fictitional place it's like okay but
again it's it's funny that we started
the show with selling dreams because
that's what you're doing
you're saying you're saying no you're
saying you're saying that oh some guys
like confident girls but you know deep
down that if a girl came in she was 250
300 pounds you would not be scared of
her stealing your man you wouldn't be
scared because you know deep down there
they're not checking for her I feel like
I've dated uh men who prefer that and I
was kind of the exception to the rule oh
why do we do this why don't you know you
know it's not true you it's like you're
laughing and you're laughing because you
know you know my dad also I'm just gonna
out you Benjamin I'm so sorry he is a
chubby chaser he prefers women and my
mother was heavier his wife was heavier
that's just his type so like we were
talking about exceptions earlier there
are exceptions to the rule guys
and then why can I ask a question then
why don't you see the richest most
successful men with plus size women if
that's true if one man when men that's
their preference it's not that they
don't of options yes and this is exactly
what I was saying
for
anything out there you're going to be
able to throw out some random story some
exceptions I get that we can't paint
with a large brush and all that but
we're talking exceptions and rules
anything you say there's going to be
well I know a rich guy that dates a big
girl I know a girl that will happily be
with some broke dude I know a guy that
will take on three kids from a from a
new chick but these are very few and far
between so it's not reality let's be
based as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we we are
demonetized on a daily basis
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible